recently The Discovery Institute you
know what I'm talking about the
intelligent design people they're the
ones who try to get creationism taught
in schools it went to court there was a
big trial even after their huge failed
court case those guys are still around
and I feel like it's still a pretty
large organization probably still a
multi-million dollar organization and
recently they have aimed their slander
machine at yours truly they follow my
social media they write articles about
my tweets they make videos about me I'm
going to talk about that here more in a
second but first wow I just realized the
last time I posted here was before my
trip to Ecuador in December what I've
been doing is I've been focusing all my
energy on stated clearly I've been doing
animations definitely go check those out
if you haven't seen them yet I did one
on bee stingers I did one on single cell
bottlenecks and I even did kind of a
stated casually Style video about chat
GPT over there where I just asked it a
bunch of questions about Evolution it
was really fun I'm still alive I
survived in Ecuador I need to put
together a video for you about that trip
it was amazing to see blue and gold
macaws in their natural habitat I wasn't
expecting that to be the thing that
really surprised me but man that took my
breath away and we did see river
dolphins this here is stock footage the
footage that we got on our cameras it
tended to be at dusk when they would
come up close to us and so the none of
the footage was all that great but we
will be doing it again next December
evotour.info is the website where you
can go sign up for the newsletter about
that if you sign up for the newsletter
you'll be alerted as soon as ticket
sales are open we're only selling 12
spots so anyway back to the intelligent
design stuff The Discovery Institute
recently I had a viewer ask me to
respond to all of the material they've
been making about me I looked into the
things they were writing honestly it
just kind of looked like garbage really
petty stuff to me it doesn't even
warrant a response but I of course am
biased maybe there are some really
legitimate criticisms that they're
throwing my way and so what I did is I
went and I asked a pro science
Evangelical Christian what he thought
Stephen peinecker is an Evangelical
Christian who runs a podcast about
Mormonism his podcast among other things
it helps Mormons understand how their
religion differs from mainstream
Evangelical Christianity on that podcast
he likes to talk to current and
ex-mormons and because I was actually
raised in the Mormon religion I used to
be a Mormon he had scheduled me to come
on during that interview I asked him as
an Evangelical Christian what do you
think about the materials The Discovery
Institute is making about my science
animations the following is a clip
showing his response if you enjoy this
clip check out the entire thing there's
a link down in the video description
without further Ado here is a pro
science Evangelical Christian responding
to the Discovery institute's attacks on
my work and it was so funny because you
know I watched you asked me to watch the
video so I watched your video and then I
watched their video one thing is that
it's classic quote mining is what is a
creationist tactic that they'll will
take once sentence or one word and and
and and just go on go off on it and make
that their whole thing and rather than
address the main aspects of what it's
whether it's an article or a
presentation like you do they're just
going to focus on one or two things that
they say Aha and then that 90 of their
videos spent talking about that that's
what that's a that's what creationists
do all the time it's a it's a tactic to
make it seem like they're engaging but
they're really not they're just they're
they're being diversion diversionary
yeah anytime there's something that
really takes hold in the community that
that becomes convincing for a lot of
people and and science any just big
discovery that people are excited about
in science the creationists kind of
machine
likes to use those keywords and produce
lots of Articles and lots of videos and
so on it's kind of like a an attempt to
censor the internet I suppose The
Discovery Institute has a has a separate
company called Evolution news where they
write articles about anything that comes
out in evolution and they just say that
it's false this is the tactic they're
using they're trying to just put out a
ton of stuff it's not a surprise they
did that to me because I'm making videos
that are used in classrooms so and
that's the key thing is that that would
make you a a direct threat to the what
they're trying to do so I I made a video
called what is the RNA World hypothesis
and again so this was this was funded by
the the center for chemical Evolution
Nicholas HUD when he and I first set out
to do a series of animations about the
origin of life one of the things that
we're trying to fight against the public
really does have a this idea that the
origin of life is already figured out
that actually is a legitimate problem
when I go to schools I'll ask students
before we watch a video have scientists
figure out the origin of life and
probably like 25 of the class will say
yes
after they watch the video I'll ask
again and maybe like one person will say
yes you know so I'm like okay our videos
are working where what we're trying to
do is show people this is not figured
out
there's a lot of progress happening and
Nick's like I want to get those high
schoolers excited so they come and end
up working for me as a researcher he's
like and right now when people think
this is already solved they're not
excited to go into original life
research why would you go oh would you
get excited to research something that's
already been figured out so there
there's some pretty strong alignment
with my concern Nicholas Hud's concern
and the discovery institute's concern
about original life stuff is we we all
agree
it's a problem that people think this
has already been solved and a lot of
that is due to bad journalism and so on
so the RNA World hypothesis video there
are four times in that video where I
stop and I point out this is not fully
worked out I'm I'm showing people what
the our RNA World hypothesis is in
general I say it's a hypothesis which
means by default if it's not figured out
I never say that it's a fact that this
is how we know that the original life
happened at the very end I talk about
different avenues that are also being
studied because we don't know if this is
this is it I also have a video about the
metabolism first hypothesis and in that
I do a lot more attacking of the RNA
World hypothesis because we're talking
about why a different hypothesis is is
is so important here
so I I do find it interesting that
they're accusing me of telling people
that this is already figured out because
that's exactly not what we're doing in
fact when I share this video in classes
I do the before and after specific
question about this topic and it's only
the kid who wasn't paying attention that
will say raise his hand and say yeah
scientists are sorry to figure this out
there there's this belief that there's
this war going on and it's kind of like
a spiritual war and that you people like
you are a direct existential threat to
Christianity American Evangelical
Christianity in particular and that
you're basically there to undermine and
destroy the faith of people
and and so by teaching evolution you're
you're you're you're going against the
Bible you're going against you're you're
rebelling against God and so in one
sense that they they almost view you
almost like a satanic person and it must
it must be weird for you to be on the
receiving end of that but that's what
motivates their worldview they really
think that that's what's going on and I
used to in many ways kind of growing up
that's what we that's kind of early on
as a young kid that's kind of what we
were taught very similarly and so when
you're watching the discovery
institute's attack on you they're not
taking into account the Nuance that
you're using and that you're you're
you're making a point to say this is
this is the best information we have at
time this is the hypothesis this is how
it works so you're describing the
hypothesis and they're they're taking is
like he's saying that this is what
happened and then see now they're
misrepresenting what you're trying to
say and so I think that we all need to
be careful on both sides is that we
don't kind of try to come across too
friendly like knowing this is it for
sure I think we all can use nuance and I
think The Discovery Institute you need
to also maybe recognize that you need to
be a little bit more honest in the way
that you're portraying John's videos
because he's not saying this is it and I
you know this is what science has
already figured out no this is what
science is exploring this is what it's
trying to understand whenever The
Discovery Institute attacks a video it
just it gets more views and I earn more
money yeah yeah so and they're paying to
advertise on your videos too so you're
they're helping fund your channel yeah